i think it is safe to say that a lot of
things have to go right for one to make
it
in the world of esports you have to
dedicate
thousands and thousands of hours to your
craft become a certifiable master
and let's not kid ourselves get absurdly
lucky
and for every single one of us hoping to
one day make a living after spending
years in the depths of matchmaking hell
there is no
end to the number of obstacles in our
way
but what if i told you that for a
certain subsection of the gaming world
those obstacles transcend awful
teammates and
gamblers luck that right down to the
engineering of their mouse and keyboard
they're starting at a disadvantage so
much so
that they literally have to learn how to
play backwards
i'm talking of course about left-handed
gamers
one of the most fascinating sub-sections
of the wild world that is competitive
gaming
and today we're going to explore how
they defy the odds
from teaching themselves to use their
mouse in the wrong hand
to cracking open and modding controllers
these guys
have done and will presumably continue
to do
whatever it takes to gain
[Applause]
suffice it to say it's a tough life for
a left-handed gamer
buying a computer or a monitor that's
easy
but trying to buy a mouse or a keyboard
if you don't click fools with your right
hand
that is a nightmare now the button is
too far away
because normally you you know you'll be
using your
sort of this finger to press it and then
maybe your thumb here to press this
button
size shape and overall performance can
help you decide
but for some left-handed gamers none of
this matters
now some of them just say [ __ ] it and
teach themselves how to play backwards
some of them even mod their own
peripherals just to play the games they
love
they've realized that plenty of
manufacturers just don't seem to give a
[ __ ] about lefty's physical limitations
so in a world that seemingly isn't
interested in accommodating left-handed
gamers
what can they do to overcome these
challenges
now certain game devs and peripheral
companies have already thought of ways
to assist them
while others have decided to give up on
them entirely but no matter what
they keep finding ways to adapt and
they'll do just about anything to make
it work
if it means that they can gain now
according to a report from the
washington post back in 2019
10 of the world's population is
left-handed
and historically i think most of you
probably know that
they've been royally [ __ ] over hell in
the middle ages left-handed people were
even accused of practicing
witchcraft because of course even satan
himself
was allegedly left-handed it's magic
he must be a witch and while it is
certainly true that kenny s
is not of this world and can be a bit of
a demon
on the server for the sake of this video
we'll be focusing on left-handed
gamers and the unprecedented ways that
they've managed
to defy the odds no matter how much of a
pc
mouse and keyboard elitist you may or
may not have become
chances are you've used a controller or
gamepad before
so let's start there controllers are
really only made to be held one way
and if you want to get good that's a
massive roadblock
nearly all of them have the majority of
the buttons located on the right side
and left-handed people are just forced
to use their non-dominant hand to do all
the heavy lifting
now some games at least allow you to
switch what analog stick controls your
movement
but you're still forced to use your
right hand for most of the inputs
one way to hold a controller dimitri
please as far back as the original xbox
you add pro halo players like walshee
pioneering the claw technique
using your middle finger on the right
trigger and resting your index finger on
the face buttons
hell i've even seen kids playing with
the damn thing upside down
okay they may be a small minority but
you get the idea
these days with the xbox elite
controllers scuff and a whole slew of
other custom controller companies giving
you the option to remap buttons to the
back of the controller
left-handed gamers are afforded even
more flexibility to suit their needs
consoles now will even allow you to
remap the face buttons to
say the d-pad if you want to move that
duty over to your left hand without
splurging on a shiny new peripheral
controller's not looking so bad now is
it mr mouse and keyboard elitist
i mean yeah let's see how that
controller stacks up in a 1v1
eyes emoji 100 firefighter
coming soon tm now for many players
facing the lefty problem across
the whole of esports that solution has
been the only option
simply play backwards in the world of
mobas for instance like
league of legends one of the greatest
mid laners in the entire world
knight has been playing with his mouse
in his left hand
his entire career and capturing that
dominant hand pinpoint precision
one player at tes now 369 once again
trying to get in there but night he's
trying to make something of this fight
here that's a double kill
now but he is still incredibly low he's
gonna hop back and get a third one and
get a heel to get out of this
but perhaps surprisingly that isn't the
industry standard
in league like many games most lefties
just
seem to teach themselves to play
right-handed to avoid the nightmare of
changing their keybinds
and although the learning curve on any
peripheral is far from trivial
it is those on pc who face the biggest
challenge
let me paint a picture for you all right
so you hop into a cs go death match
server and get ready to frag out
now most people have their mouse in
their right hand and they have their
left hand
situated on or around the wazzed keys of
their keyboard now
imagine that you're left-handed and
using the exact same equipment
you simply move your mouse into your
left hand and put your right hand
on the waz keys seems simple enough
right
well no it actually [ __ ] sucks since
the movement keys for most games are
located on the left side of your
keyboard
you're playing with far less space
between your hands
and for that reason we've seen
left-handed players like walk sick
play on a much higher sensitivity the
lack of desk space or mouse pad space
literally gave him no other option
but like i mentioned earlier some
players have just taught themselves to
play backwards
and this works for them because it's
literally all they've ever known
look at the inimitable kenny s for
instance he is arguably the most
legendary opera in the whole of
counter-strike and his entire legacy was
built on him playing with his mouse in
his
non-dominant hand rather than messing
around with his keyboards
and he still manages to hit inhuman
flicks
like this the shots completely detached
from the action kenny first at the back
he finds the shot but he's being
pressured up close he needs shocks to
support him he's watching for a flight
for one squad
oh my god kenny gets an incredible kill
against sixer i don't even see the flick
he hits that shot somehow and it's
another round for g2
what was that last shot but not every
player is willing to learn to play
backwards so they continue using their
left hand for their mouse
the thing is in doing so some
left-handed was gamers
experience discomfort in their wrists
because their hands are
simply too close together so to give you
an idea as to just how
shitty this feels i decided to play 20
minutes of cs go death match
with my mouse in my left hand and my waz
keys in my right
and holy [ __ ] was it ugly
come on come on dude come on
[Music]
it's the worst thing that's ever
happened to me
yep it's about how i thought this was
gonna go
yep that sounds about right so yeah in
case you couldn't tell
i hated just about every second of that
now
hearing all of this you're probably
asking the same question that i did when
i first learned about all of it
which is why don't these people just
change their keyboard layout and
buy a [ __ ] left-handed mouse now
plenty of games will allow you to remap
your keys to ijkl
but it's not as simple as that because
as you know
there's more to gaming than movement the
shift and control keys are commonly used
in many games and unless your hands are
the size of
winston's from overwatch then good luck
using your pinky finger to hit them and
that's why
many players just make their own
personal keybinds based on what game
they're playing
8 4 5 and six are my movement keys and
all of my four fingers sit on the number
pad
and my thumb sits on the directional pad
which has its own set of abilities and
buttons doesn't that just look
[ __ ] awful anyway this brings us to
the
final nail in the coffin mice
now some manufacturers like razer have
their own mice which are dedicated to
left-handed gamers
but most of the big names like logitech
steel series and zowie
have historically opted to just go
ambidextrous
for years they have been making mice
that work for just about everyone
left handed or not but right now more
than ever
we are in the midst of a massive
left-handed
gamer mouse crisis you see with each
passing generation of peripherals
competitors have wanted their mice to be
smaller lighter
and without wires which makes sense
right you can flick these 60 gram whole
filled swiss cheese looking things
faster than ever
some of the most popular mice like the
zowie s2
and the logitech g pro were famous for
being some of the best ambidextrous mice
on the market
but times have changed and zowie
specifically
has discontinued all of their
ambidextrous mice
while the newest iteration of the g pro
the super light
has removed the option to swap the
buttons from left to right
but yes physically still more the same
minus those interchangeable side buttons
so lefties i'm sorry they alienated you
this time around
and that is the untold truth of how
lefties have been able to cut it in pc
gaming
from learning to play backwards to
remapping their keybinds
to making do with less desk space than a
burgeoning 13 year old
hiko now to be fair there is a bit of a
safe haven for lefties
sort of in fighting games most players
use either
arcade sticks or pads and we've already
talked about controllers
sticks feature the well stick on the
left
and the buttons on the right now for
most left-handed players this works out
just fine
because their dominant hand is already
on the stick where movement is
much more important and some players
have taken up
the hitbox which functions just like a
stick
but with movement buttons instead of the
well actual stick
some players have even adopted the seth
killian
cross-handed method with their right
hand on the stick and their left hand on
the buttons
but they're part of a very small
minority back in 2012
american peripheral company niko
actually released
an ambidextrous fight stick allowing
players to move the stick to either side
but it never really caught on instead
some
left-handed players begin modding their
own controllers
they take the controller apart rotate
the stick 180 degrees
remap all of their buttons and then play
with the entire unit
upside down just to switch what side the
stick is on
you can simply just
take the whole lever right now it's
facing this way same thing
now you want to rotate it and then put
it back in
and screw it back in as you can see
the lever is in its correct orientations
now although in some cases they've
literally had to take apart and rebuild
their controllers
the ease of the common fight stick has
allowed lefties in the fgc
a slight reprieve from the battle on pc
but i mean come on like they have to
build their own [ __ ] controllers
which in many ways is what makes the
untold story of lefties in
esports so fascinating we took their
mice away
keyboard manufacturers ignored them from
the origin of the product's design
and we forced them to play backwards and
yet still we find players like walksik
kenny and knight at the highest level of
esports competition
making it up as they go but i felt
really bad for those kids
in the clips like i felt really bad for
the first time
i was like bro you just like he like you
know some kid was like sitting top mid
with an op
and i'm running up at how many peaks and
he misses the op shot so he has to
reload and i'm just like hounding him
down with his head
it's just like dude like you gotta hit
your once man you gotta hit that like
you can't
miss that shot like that's miserable